I'm from Boston where everybody
everybody grow up in everybody everybody
played hockey growing up and any Boston
comedian plays hockey and Denis Leary's
always anytime he throws a benefit
everyone has to play off yeah then I
find out that you yeah play hockey yeah
we got to wrap this up yeah did you play
hockey at night I do I do I actually
have a game tonight and I like have all
my gear in my car and I'm gonna go right
from here to the rink and it's funny
because when they scheduled this they
sort of said like hey can you do this
night and I was like I have an immense
adult hockey game that when you say this
you mean this show this wait so they
came to you and said you have the
amazing opportunity yes to be on the
Conan show yes
and you you suddenly said it's that or
my hockey night look I am like I am at
least 11th in assists right now so if I
go tonight ain't net a couple like we
are talking goals assists like I'm gonna
raise the bar he asked you a question
what is the age of the people playing
hockey either it's older now okay here's
my next question do older people when
they're playing hockey do they get into
fights yeah absolutely even though
you're not professional hockey players
no you get into because it's like a
week's full of like you know stress that
you're been putting out on the ice so
you get into it with other guys and
ultimately you push and shove and then
you like start start and kiss yeah yeah
yeah naturally yeah make a sexual
makeout I know you start yelling at each
other but it sucks because I have to
wear like a full cage like when I play
because I'm you know in this industry
and there's no on television right is
your fortune yeah and there's nothing
less like tough than having to wear a
cape no one else is doing it Noel says
no you're the only guy yeah well I'm
like one of a few but which is ironic
because you look at my teeth really
anything this guy doesn't need to wear
it kay if anything like this could be a
blessing in disguise I get hit in the
mouth with a puck and I could just start
over how do they react when they see
with a cage on your face and they go
they call you no they say nice cage you
would you know and I'm like yeah well
I'm a Hollywood actor
there's no comeback there's no comeback
just keep this thing smooth make up I
have to moisturize in an hour
don't think it happened to this hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography